back to the action Einhorn in the big
blind Steve [ __ ] first to act he pulled
over to China's who calls for 400 Jamie
call me know should be raising or
folding especially with a dangerous
player like David Einhorn in the big
line
Perkins looks at Queen 10 raises court
makes it 1,400 I'm on call six seven of
clubs and Shana's promptly folks what if
he's not willing to call modest raised
what is he doing in the hand you should
have just folded on top so it heads up
to the flop iron one and Perkins our two
most experienced players lot comes deuce
King King chinos kicking himself for
folding the King ten looks like a queen
two kings park acquires a bed of 2000
with nothing
Einhorn makes the quick call with just a
flush draw
turn card turn comes eight of diamond
nine one misses his drop fell Chuck
Perkins checks and Einhorn wisely takes
the free card river
Einhorn makes his flush and Bill Perkins
reaching for his chips but 4,000 wrong
did Perkins representing the hand that I
know it actually has that is always a
tough Bluff to pull off and as you'd
expect Einhorn raises to 11,000 Vic I
see my cards and they know I'm only
kidding so merciful [ __ ] told you it
laughter I don't want takes down the pot
a little bit of revenge for Einhorn you
still really mad about the one-drop come
on